ciao ragazzi non vi aveva visto sono fa
dj e vi do il benvenuto della mia
splendida casa in questa è l'entrata
estate per scoprire un posto
meraviglioso ma perché non cominciamo
dalla porta
questa fantastica porta è stata staccata
direttamente dall'enterprise del price
navicella è veramente incredibile
guardatela non è proprio simile alla
porta di casa di mia nonna ma è molto
più tecnologica molto più avanzata
eppure non finisce qui qui perché ero il
proprio qui di fianco abbiamo il logo di
falli geo ricorda un po come se fossimo
a tokyo di notte ma nonostante questo
funziona perché se per caso ti
dimentichi di essere in casa di
familiari quando l'occhio ti cade sul
logo ti ricordi immediatamente di cileni
sono proprio in casa di favi j
se sei una persona che si dimentica le
cose non te lo puoi dimenticare lo
stesso proprio come mia mamma che ogni
tanto dice a e mio figlio
tutto quello che state per vedere oggi è
stato reso possibile grazie a vodafone
lo potete vedere da questo splendido
logio sopra la volta di questa era
soltanto all'entrata
ma andiamo a dare un'occhiata al resto
fini ragazzi diamo un'occhiata a durare
le mie cose preferite che in casa a
questo meraviglioso cabinato ricami nato
è stato personalizzato ad hoc per me ea
un sacco di giochi al suo interno e mi
piacciono nel sacco ad esempio
questa è la mia partita su un puzzle
bobble mi piace giocarci tutte quelle
volte in cui la mia ragazza a casa mia e
sia lei sia tutti quanti i miei amici
quando vengono a casa mia vogliono
giocare a puzzle bobble credo che non
vengano neanche a casa mia
per me ma vengono solo per giocare a
puzzle bobble quindi le diamo
un'occhiata veloce a questo gameplay
[Musica]
sfondo veramente molto scarso questo è
veramente fantastico ed è uno dei pezzi
migliori che ho in casa ma dimenticatelo
per adesso perché stiamo per passare
alla mia splendida cucina
venite con me benvenuti nella mia
splendida cucina questa è la cucina
migliore al mondo e vi spiego perché in
prima di tutto la funzione elettrico e
soprattutto appoggiarci oggetti di sopra
ha ad esempio ho inserito la pianta ma è
una pianta finta e ho anche inserito un
buon grado rante che serve a dare buon
profumo a questa zona della casa andiamo
quindi ad esaminare il frigo che sembra
un po un armadio effettivamente se
guardiamo all'interno ci sono soltanto
schifezze ma la cosa più importante di
tutte è questa l'app di mandorla buono è
let's go spostiamoci dall'altra parte
della cucina abbiamo è fantastico
microonde una fantastica lavastoviglie e
abbiamo anche un forno con attaccate
delle calamite sopra da qui invece
abbiamo il fornello che come potete
notare non è un fornello induzione
antico perché preferisco molto di più
vedere la fiamma quando cucino quindi
mai perché in realtà un cuscino mai però
questo è un altro discorso è comunque
proseguiamo cha abbiamo la macchinetta
del caffè ma anche in questo caso io non
bevo caffè quindi è un po inutile
dopodiché abbiamo anche un sacco di test
sì devo veramente un sacco di temi e
questo è il motivo del perché libro più
di tutti quanti voi miei ragazzi abbiamo
il lavandino e abbiamo anche un sacco di
credenze dove inserire la roba da
mangiare partiamo dagli snack
qui abbiamo i piatti abbiamo le tasse
abbiamo anche un sacco di oggetti della
dubbia utilità ad esempio questo che
serve per pulire il naso lo riempi con
l'acqua e poi lo versi tutto è
fantastico in casa mia
questa era la cucina mi piace veramente
un sacco la mia cucina e voglio anche
farvi notare il mio lampadario dario
perché anche il lampadario è stato fatto
da vodafone è una vera figata perché
puoi accendere spegnere il lampadario
solamente utilizzando alexa ad esempio a
lei sa spegne cucina è proprio una magia
quindi ragazzi è ora di passare al
salotto
ed eccoci arrivati nel mio fantastico
salotto risposto subito la vostra
attenzione e proprio qui dove abbiamo la
nostra pedana ed è molto bello perché
vuoi cambiare i colori
vuoi avere qualsiasi tipo di colore
anche sul pavimento è fantastico ma
venite qui vi mostro il resto di questo
fantastico posto partendo proprio dal
divano
il divano è di un colore rosso veramente
acceso è un divano molto pregiato fatto
dalla marca di design cartelle e grazie
mille cartella anche per questo
fantastico tavolo abbiamo delle serie
splendide abbiamo un tavolo splendido e
abbiamo anche il tavolino di cartello
dove possa appoggiare il telecomando
vi mostro anche l'altro tavolino
dall'altra parte del divano e proprio
qui è tutto questo è stato prodotto da
cartello
grazie mille cartella dove cup è la
camera
ma non finisce qui perché abbiamo queste
meravigliose mensole ha voluto creare
uno spazio dedicato ai miei fan co pop
come potete vedere alla mia collezione
mancano due pop 1 qui è uno qui se
volete regalarmi qualche poco al
prossimo evento sono pronto il divano è
veramente molto comodo
puoi sederti così puoi guardare la tv
puoi sederti anche in questo modo poi
anche mettersi a dormire se voglia puoi
fare tutte le cose che io faccio nella
mia morning routine ma ma guardiamo un
altro pezzo importante della casa del
cibo di traun berberi tondeggiante e you
can eat with your friends for friends
forse dire andiamo a dare un'occhiata a
questo ragazzone qui si chiama social
build vuoi registrare al suo interno
qualsiasi cosa tu voglia puoi registrare
il gameplay puoi registrare un eagle
puoi registrare anche i podcast e gli
mostrerò tra poco che parlando
all'interno poi da fuori non potete
sentire quello che sto dicendo come
vedete non si sente proprio niente di
quello che dico all'interno per vostra
informazione stavo citando il filosofo
hegel veramente fantastico come potete
vedere c'è un setup all'interno con una
tastiera con un'altra camera e per
concludere il grande logo di vodafone
applicato sul vetro della porta che ci
ricorda che questo è uno spazio vodafone
ma non abbiamo ancora finito con il
salotto perché abbiamo una grandissima è
grandissima così ama mobile al mondo da
del salotto mobile del salotto è proprio
questo abbiamo queste fantastiche
mensole con i miei oggetti sopra abbiamo
anche button per il 100 mila iscritti e
la stoffa world of warcraft uno dei miei
giochi preferiti oltre questo abbiamo
anche questa splendida videocamera super
performante e può muoversi a 360 gradi
con questa si possono fare video
direttamente ne sarò qui l'altro senza
preoccuparsi nell'inquadratura perché la
camera
ti segue quando ti muovi in questo
preciso momento è spenta ma quando lo
accendo la camera può seguirmi oltre
questo abbiamo anche in cromo ni
pensiamo bisogno di fare le vide in
salotto non devo portarmi neanche il mio
dello studio perché questi sono
attaccati direttamente al muro pensate
che ne abbiamo addirittura due
per finire vi mostro anche la mia
playstation 1 è anche il miglior gioco
mai fatto nella
ingranaggio di metallo solido abbiamo
anche in conto fuor e le carte dei
tarocchi di giorgio con queste carte
potete scegliere il vostro stand a me ad
esempio è uscito lo store ma non
facciamo troppe referenze di giorgio e
passiamo anche alla parte inferiore
della mensola
come potete vedere abbiamo le console
playstation 4
la nuova xbox e abbiamo anche la nuova
playstation 5 abbiamo anche i caricatori
per il joypad della playstation 5 così
non bisogna caricarli quei cavi [ __ ]
vi è qua sotto abbiamo un altro oggetto
che io adoro tantissimo anzi oserei dire
che anche uno dei miei preferiti
se può accendere e si può spegnere il
blocco di supermario le sei core of two
the best thing in the wall non in
industria abbiamo questo meraviglioso
televisore è veramente un di vuole due
fantastico grazie mille lg per avermi
fatto mettere questo splendido
televisore sul muro è perfetto in tutto
in particolare per il gamer
infatti quando gioco la console la
qualità dell'immagine ed ha paura a un
tempo di risposta straordinario e laghi
bassissimo in base al genere di gioco si
possono cambiare i filtri per vedere
meglio i nemici e tante altre varie cose
grazie leggi per questo fantastico tv
oled e quindi passiamo alla prossima
parte della casa per entrare nella mia
camera da letto e parlo veramente
abbassa a bassa voce perché non voglio
svegliare nessuno all'entrata abbiamo
questo ragazzone cuore questo è il
dorato gioco bottone l'ho ricevuto hanno
fatto gli ho raggiunto il mio primo
milione di iscritti e partiamo con
questo splendido armadio
lo ha fatto fare su misura apposta per
che raggiungesse il soffitto
ma apriamo in un attimo e vediamo che
cosa c'è all'interno
vi faccio vedere qual è il mio indumento
preferito è proprio questo qui questo è
veramente la mia felpa preferita mario
ma spostandoci dall'armadio abbiamo
anche questo fantastico letto anche come
potete vedere sono molto maniacale ho
messo i cuscini proprio al centro non
sono molto sicuro che lo terrò per tanto
tempo perché non è poi così grande
stiamo parlando di una piazza senza ed
esine english sul prossimo qui ma diamo
un'occhiata a questa sibariti cam esso
sono appoggiate sopra un sacco di cose
che anche il mappamondo taio e ci sono
anche funghi non so bene come mai
insomma se ci spostiamo abbiamo anche un
distributore molto particolare
distribuisce menez
anche questo televisore oled è stato
prodotto da lg e dello stesso modello di
quello in salotto ma un po più piccolo
ma vi mostro anche questo fantastico
strumento che è un bel mi è stato
regalato qualche tempo fa da davi e 504
lo guardo ogni volta prima di
addormentarvi così i miei sogni sono
veramente fantastici
grazie da via e 504 per questo
fantastico basso le èlite now
if you like bass abbiamo quest'altra
fantastica mensola o un sacco di mensole
in questa casa è un sacco di foto con i
miei migliori amici e di qua ci sono
anche tutti i miei altri amici
in queste foto non è presente giampiero
a una volta c'era stato molto acceso
non abbiamo ancora finito seriamente non
ci sono l'ultima cosa che vi mostro
nella mia camera da letto e questa è una
libreria ma è molto [ __ ] perché se noi
andiamo là giugno potete vedere la forma
della libreria che è un fantastico robot
fatto così no questa è arte ah no questo
è il colore ha detto che il paese
sarebbe stata la solita di come si
doppia
e all'interno ha messo delle cosè alle
quali tengo molto perché alla fine sono
molto filosofico e anche un sacco
romantico e come ultima cosa nella casa
abbiamo il fantastico studio lo avete
già visto probabilmente in molti video
ma mai mai così show vi faccio vedere
l'entrata prima di tutto abbiamo la
serigrafia direttamente sulla porta e
adesso entriamo dove avviene la magia
andiamo studio e la parte migliore di
casa ovviamente è veramente fantastico e
abbiamo questa super seria fatta da lino
sonego con il brand di vodafone e di fa
vj bandire posso sedermi proprio come
morpheus si tiene sulla sua
nabucodonosor abbiamo anche questi due
fantastici monitor i fari per farmi
assomigliare a barbara d'urso durante i
video abbiamo anche delle luci incassate
nel muro che rendono tutto quanto
l'ambiente molto molto più figo e
abbiamo anche due fantastici computer
diamogli un'occhiata farebbe registrare
duni basta carezza accende i fari
[Applauso]
pronto per lavoro la prima cosa che farò
è accendere il computer che è veramente
incredibile ma io non so bene se questo
sia strizza ma funziona molto bene per
raffreddare gola tar è veramente un
computer pazzesco ed è tutto tondo
si può anche ruotare possiamo anche
aprirlo con questo bottone sul retro si
apre il computer è come potete vedere
questa splendida 3090 l'invidia abita il
benvenuto oltre il raffreddamento
abbiamo anche un fantastico processore i
nove molto molto figo e con questo vi
posso giocare ad una fantastica partita
su bwin
dopodiché abbiamo anche un secondo
computer e con tante cose molto figo ma
passiamo al setup dei monitor e delle
tastiere dimostra la mia fantastica
tastiera che in dotazione aveva anche
questo coso molto morbido non conosco il
nome di questo oggetto ma chi se ne
frega e anche i monitor sono stati fatti
delle grazie mille lg per i monitor e
che hanno una qualità e una velocità
eccezionale una fluidità incredibile e
ragazzi siete science e grazie ancora lg
però tutti gli schermi di catania tris
di coccio presente che sia i monitor
siete le vittorie
li trovate in descrizione da g le faccio
vedere una cosa molto [ __ ] abbiamo
queste inaspettate cuffie proprio
nell'angolino che non sono proprio le
prime curve che avevo quando ho iniziato
a registrare i miei m parliamo del 2013
che potete vedere da allora dove siamo
arrivati e veramente pazzesco se ci
pensate
quindi ragazzi questo era il mio tour di
casa e questo ovviamente è il bagno
questa è la vasca da bagno e in questa
fantastica posizione voglio concludere
questo video non dimenticatemi ragazzi
come sempre di mettere mi piace di
commentare leader
e guardate la descrizione per tutti gli
incubi
iscrivetevi al mio canale ci vediamo il
prossimo video ciao
[Musica]